So when we do this, we have, with the ViewPort,
we have its height as a percept and we have its contents a, as a percept. For
the scroll bar, we have the position of the handle is a percept and
also the size is a percept. But we don't currently have any percepts for
the FileManager, and in fact the user doesn't directly see the file manager.
However if we took our 40,000 foot view of the system, and, and
we said what is external to the system and
what is internal to the system. The user is external to the system. Users, is,
is the one that's going to be taken advantage of the, of the system. But
also, the file system itself, the operating system is external to the system and
the operating system is the one with which the FileManager component has to
deal. So we're going to treat the operating system as an external acto,r and
the FileManager is going to interact with that external actor.
And as far as the FileManager is concerned, it has an attribute which is
the document. Providing that as a, as a resource to the rest of the system, and
it's, it's, it's It also has an interface to this external actor,
that is, the actor has to provide that, that document. So we have an attribute
there which is, the document which is a sequence of, a sequence of lines.